welcome to this course on how you can
use WordPress and AI to create a fully
functional store that sells products
created by AI I'm Bo KS and I teach this
course I recently received this package
in the mail and let's see what it is I
haven't actually opened this yet so
um okay it's a sticker I ordered this AI
generated sticker using the e-commerce
site I will show you how to create in
this tutorial with this method you don't
have to mail anything yourself but even
if you don't want to create an
e-commerce site this course can still
help you you'll learn how to create a
WordPress website and get help from
artificial intelligence to create any
website you need a domain name and a
place to host the files in this course
we'll be using hostinger hostinger
provided a grant to make this course
possible hostinger is optimized for
WordPress sites and they offer a 99.9%
guarantee they also have recently
Incorporated some AI tools to make web
development easier this is actually the
first time I've seen this sticker and it
looks pretty nice so to get started with
your domain name and hosting you can go
to hostinger.com or there's a lot of
other hosting providers as well they may
or may not have some of these AI tools
that hosting or offers you can choose
the plan premium or business for you if
you want AI tools you do need to choose
the business plan so we just do add to
cart and basically you're just going to
go through these steps to add this to
your to your cart to create an account
and to buy your hosting and your domain
once you get logged into to hostinger
and you have your account you can click
claim domain it may not look exactly the
same as my button but you should have
that button somewhere and then you may
have to experiment with some different
domains to find one that's not already
taken but I'm going to try coder
stickers coders stickers.com because I'm
creating a website to sell stickers for
software
developers okay and the reason why I was
able to get on my first try is because I
already checked some domains and that
like the first mini mini I checked
didn't exist but I already had this one
in mind because I I knew it wasn't taken
yet so I'm going to claim that domain
okay and good I have my fake contact
information because uh one time I
accidentally put in my real contact
information and then I got tons of uh
spam calls in marketing so you either
want to use you're supposed to use your
your real contact information but I I if
you do make sure you uh choose the
option to hide it because they will
contact you okay finished
registration now that you have your
domain depending on how you purchase
your hosting
uh you can connect your website to your
hosting there may be a different method
depending on if you got your domain
first or your hosting first but I'm
going to connect it to the business web
hosting so you may have purchased the
business web hosting you may have
purchased the premium web hosting or
completely different one but I'm going
to connect it to the business web
hosting cuz it has the most AI tools
associated with it and this course is
all about how to use AI tools to develop
a website quickly so we are going to
create a new
website and then so we can either do
WordPress with AI or hosting or Builder
with AI hosting or Builder is part of
Hosting or it's their own builder now
WordPress with AI is obviously WordPress
and WordPress is going to give a a lot
more plugins so there's going to be a
little more customized you can do so it
is a little harder it says right here
needs more experience so if you just
want something simple you're going to be
able to build a website very quick with
this website builder you just basically
type in the website you want and the AI
Builder just builds the whole website
for you but we're going to go with
WordPress because that's going to give
us a little more uh customization
options so I'll go select WordPress with
AI and then we just have to set the
language administrator uh email and the
passord
[Music]
password and now we can choose what
plugins we want now a lot of these are
going to be helpful I mean this is going
to help us track the statistics and this
will help with email Subs subscribers if
we want to email list all in Wise SEO is
kind of this built-in thing that will
help with search engine optimization
which we want if we don't forms we're
going to want WP form and then
woocommerce we're going to add this
because we are creating a store so now I
I'm going to skip the Google site kit
and just hit
continue now we can choose our theme or
our template and there's going to be a
bunch of different options depending on
what we want to do so I could click show
more and we can see a lot more
now if uh if you're creating a Blog the
hosting or blog is actually pretty good
one because a lot of stuff is set up to
work with it since we're creating a
store I'm going to go with
storefront and now here is the AI one of
the AI tools that we're going to look at
automate your text Creation with AI so I
just have to put in my brand name my
business details and then uh chat gbt or
probably more realistically the open AI
API is going to generate some piece of
content for the website so I'm going to
put for the brand
name code
stickers and then we'll just put a
description here and then here's a
description which I actually did create
with chat gbt I told it what we wanted
and just put it right in it then it came
up with this description I'll just read
a little bit we are your go-to
destination for the expressive and
whimsicle developer theme stickers that
add a spark of creativity to your
workspace our extens extensive
collection of design is designed to
celebrate the quirks and culture of the
programming community and that kind of
gives a little information little some
examples bug related stickers language
specific decals uh way to Adorn your
laptop notebooks and Beyond so all this
information is going to be taken by the
the AI Builder tool to create the
content that the the initial content for
our website so I'll just hit continue oh
you can also um look at like it has an
example and then these green lines here
will indicate how good of a description
you have created so if your description
isn't very good like if it's like a
short description um you're you're not
going to have as many green
lines so see it's going to be just
yellow here but I'm going to put that
all back and then we'll hit
continue okay so I'm going to you can
either uh claim a domain which we
already have or choose a do domain we
already created the domain so we'll
choose coders stickers.com
and then I'll just click finish
setup and so now it's uh just putting it
all together it's initializing the setup
and creating all the
pages okay we can see that content
Generation by AI is underway so it's
just happening in the background so we
are going to either go directly into
editing the website or the hosting or
control panel let's start by going to
the hosting or control panel and then
we'll go into the editing the
website okay uh we can see that the SSL
is installed automatically which is
really good I'm not going to update my
address right now but uh this is good
that the SSL was installed so we can
have a secure website and that just
happens automatically through hostinger
before we start setting up the website
let's set up the email so you get a free
email and it's pinning setup so I'll
just click setup
and uh we you can see we have a few
different options we're just going to
get the free basic
one and I'm just going to be at Bow
atcoder stickers.com and then we put the
password and Recovery
email
and create new
account okay so now we can access the
web mail right here so if I put in the
password and that is my recovery email
okay we are in the email account so
insert emails sent by you are not marked
as spam we can set the DK
dkim so let's do that for now so it says
setting up the dkim record for your
domain will help prevent your emails
from going to spam which is definitely
something we want to do so let's so to
set up the dkim record we need to be on
the hosting or control panel and then
I'll go to the emails tab email
accounts and then we'll go to manage
here and it's actually giving us an
indication of what we need to do your
email reputation is currently po add SPF
and dkim Records to improve it can click
here or I'm going click down here where
it says email
reputation and then we here have here
I'm going to scroll down a little
more and it's going to basically give us
the instructions
here so we're going to get the DNS host
name here and then back on the the main
hosting or dashboard I'm going to go to
domains then I'm going to
manage the domain and then I'm going to
click on dnsname
servers okay now where it says manage
DNS records I'm going to go to the type
txt and then for name I'm just going to
paste in the name we had before that I
copied and then I need to get this txt
record value and paste that in here the
TTL is going to just stay the same and
I'll click add record
now you may not need to do this if it's
already if you already have the record
but whether you're creating a new record
or you're adding a record you're going
to say I've added txt records to my DNS
control panel and then verify changes oh
it's verified okay and so now both of
these are verified and we should be all
good so we can get rid of this we
definitely don't want
notifications and there is a desk type
desktop app if you want to set that up
but other than that you can now email
and receive emails to your email address
here okay now that we're we're back on
the hosting dashboard and now we want to
start making modifications to our
website so there's a few ways to do it
one of them is just to click on this
admin pan panel
here okay our website is published and
it's going to give you a list of things
that you can can do the first thing is
upload your logo and then you'll notice
here that we have an AI assistant which
we'll talk about in a little bit but
first of all let's actually do this and
you can see that there is an AI logo
maker so I'm going to go to the AI logo
maker this is from hostinger and I am
going to put the the website name which
is coder
stickers and I will put the brand
description from before and just click
Start
creating and then we just see what type
of logo do we want I'm going go with an
abstract icon and then we can we have we
start with one credit so you can
generate a logo but I'm just going to
use a logo I already have so after you
have your logo we can just go to
appearance
customize and here is going to be the
customizer to customize the
page and it's going to kind of walk us
through it through us here and when it
says uh add your logo so let's do that
right now so I'm going to select the
logo okay and this is actually an AI
generated logo and I'll just click
select now it's kind of a busy logo I
could have gone with something more
simple but it's just up to you what you
want and it's going to walk us through
it's also going to walk us through how
to customize the navigation
menus and so you can see the navigation
menus that we have right here home C
check out now you can see this is very
simple but we are going to um actually
customize it to make it a little nicer
and we're not going to go through all
this stuff right now um we're actually
going to come back later to do some of
these you can choose your accent color
your color your buttons and then you
want to save and publish when you're
when you're ready um we'll just save and
publish this with our logo so then let's
just kind of look at what the page looks
like so far
so you can see it says
express your uh developer theme stickers
from Cod stickers.com now un
unfortunately when I put in the the
description I put the URL wrong and it's
supposed to be coders stickers.com but
we can easily go in and update that
stuff but one thing you can see is that
this text is all just created uh by AI
so uh we can see um there's basically
different blog posts that's created for
our our our uh store express yourself
with developer theme stickers from codes
stickers.com and then it gives a whole
description of what's on the site
express your coding Persona with
whimsicle developer
stickers and so it's going to create a a
few different articles another one
express yourself with wisle developer
themed stickers so it looks like some of
these articles have very similar titles
and uh text but we can actually go
through and easily update this so add a
spark of creativity or workspace with
code stickers express your coding
personality with codee stickers so it
has all these built-in articles that we
can go through and update if we want
right now let's look at how to more
quickly update what this looks like so
this is the homepage with a different
blog post and we're going to be updating
what all this looks like pretty soon
here but we have the cart uh cart is
currently empty
checkout um where you can actually check
out after you order something we haven't
added any products yet though uh my
account and Shop
so shop there's no products but we're
going to add some products now I'm back
at the admin page and we are going to
get to the AI system in a minute but
let's do some basic things to make our
website look a little better for now so
I'm going to go to appearance and then
I'm going to go to storefront now that
is the name of our theme so if you use a
different theme there may be a different
way to customize it but since we're
creating a store I'm going to customize
it through this page here basically it's
going to walk us through it so I'm going
to go to let's
go so now it's already going
to uh make the page look a little
different from before before it started
with the blog now it's going to come
right into this welcome page shop by
category and you can see we have new in
we recommend fan favorites uh but if we
click here
accessories it's going to have some
products so these are just some sample
products that we can and uh customize
later basically now this store is
looking a little better it's it's filled
out a little bit and you can see what
it's going to look like and right now
there's just 12 sample products here but
we are going to update all this so it
can be customized for our our
use so let's start customizing this a
little further for one I think this is
kind of a little too tall so I'm going
to switch this out to a shorter version
of this logo and we're going to put this
whole big thing in the welcome page so
let's see how we would do that I'm going
to go to site
identity and then change logo and then
I'm just going to change to one I I
basically use an image editing software
to uh make get just the text and not the
stuff inside the text so I'm going to
also add an ALT text so I can put coder
stickers logo
and then hit
select and then crop
image okay and now we have this so it's
not quite as tall okay now I'm going to
add a site icon so do you remember in
the full version there was like a
computer with a little face in it so I'm
going to use that as a site icon so I
already cut out that picture but now I'm
going to use this upscale program this
is a free program for Mac OS and I think
there is a Windows version too and I can
just bring in this is that little face
that I cut out and now I'm just going to
upscale it and I have on the digital art
setting and now you can see it's going
to look a lot better now now we can get
it to be the right um the right
resolution of 512 x 512 and then I just
use an image editing to get exactly 512
x 512 and then I can set the site icon
and just bring it in here and then I'll
put
icon
okay okay so we got the icon and now I
can go back
here and now we can go through if we
want and update a lot of these things
like the header image that be behind
here we could update the the footer so
that's what's down here like if I um
change the background color to Yellow
you can see it changes to Yellow well we
we don't want to do that let's change it
to the same yellow in this coder
stickers logo so to get that that that
color we're going to have to figure out
the hex value if I click here um I I
already got the hex value in my image
editor program and then I can just paste
it right in here so if we go down here
now we have this as the same color in
our logo and then you can see see we can
go through and basically change any
colors we want and then you can just
keep customizing a few other things and
then once you're done you can hit we can
hit publish now I'm just going to
actually just go copy this this website
and go to the website so this is what it
looks like so far so you can see now
it's actually filling in all these
things like the we recommend fam
favorites on sale best sellers we're
going to make some additional
adjustments so let me go back here and
then I hit X we'll go back over to
here so if you want you can get some
other designs and extensions like here
we're not going to do it but if we click
check them out we can see some other um
other themes that we can get now some of
them are going to cost money some of
them are going to be free but like if I
click here we can see this one is a free
download for this theme we're just going
to use the basic theme that we already
have for now visit the site here and
once so I already have had it open but I
could also just click here visit site
and then once I'm visiting the site
let's see how we can edit this page well
I'm just going to go different pages are
edited in different ways but for this
main page I'm going to just click edit
page up
here and then it's going to kind of tell
you about the the block editor but I can
kind of go over that so what I'm going
to do is get rid of this heading um I'm
going to actually just get rid of all
this text
and we are going to add some more text
but first i'm going to um type slash and
then we can add an image and we'll go to
the media library we'll use this one
that's already in our media
library and then I'm going to make this
a centered a
line
Center and we can change some settings
about it so instead of it being so big
we can go to medium we can go to
thumbnail and I'm going to go to medium
here and obviously this doesn't really
look good on this other image so we're
going to put a different image in the
background and uh you can kind of do a
mix of creating images with AI or we can
go and get some royaltyfree images so
I'm going to have the background image
selected and I'm going to click replace
and we'll do open media library and here
instead of using this image I'm going to
go to pixels which has some royaltyfree
images there's a few pages for
royaltyfree images or you can use an AI
image generator so I'm going to
say code
background actually let's try software
background okay I don't like these with
chat GPT I can create an image so I'm
going to say create a light
colorful
background image filled with
software
code now there's plenty of other image
generators if you don't have access to
Dolly 3 or chat GPT uh and you can also
use the royaltyfree
images okay I'm just going to go with
this one so I'm going to download this
image obviously you could spend more
time on this if you wanted and then I'll
upload the
image and then I can make some
adjustments like if I go to
block um I can click here and now I can
make it lighter I am going to make it
lighter so then the logo will stand out
a little more now we could spend a
little more time making this match a
little more but we'll just continue if
you want when you're making your own
store you can uh spend as much time as
you want on making the different things
look good actually we'll do one more
thing we'll put in a heading here and
I'll say heading now we'll just put our
slogan which is going to be stick with
code code with
stickers and I'm also going to Center
that now we can see that there's these
short codes that can put in different
things like uh the short code it's going
to put in all the categories on top and
then it's going to put in different
products and these products see if I
click on here it highlights this whole
new product section and if I look over
here it's going to say display a grid of
your newest products so this section is
always is going to show newest products
this section is always going to show the
handpick products display a selection of
handpick products in the grid and fam
favorites uh this is the ones that ra
the the top now these are automatically
generated based on the criteria um so if
we go to we recommend you can choose
what's going to show up do you want the
the pro you can turn off product image
um you can turn off product title takes
a little bit to update but you can
change the price you can turn on on and
off the rating and stuff like this and
then here here products here's where you
can choose the products the you can see
we have hoodie hoodie with pocket hoodie
with zipper so the products can be
chosen right here for what you recommend
but then some of these are just
developed automatically like fan
favorites these are going to be
automatically based on the rating and
but there's an other settings you can do
for each section and then you can choose
the on sale products now personally I
think this is too much so you don't need
all these set these sections so I'm I'm
going to get rid of some of them I'm
going to get rid of on sale uh best
sellers I can just basically delete
it I'll I'll just keep fan I'll just
keep the we recommend and fan favorites
and then we also have no no we won't
even have fan favorites we're trying to
simplify this
store and we're just going to have um
new n and we recommend except I want to
uh change the order of the SE
so I want to get this we
recommend above the the new end so see
this I can select this section the we
recommend section and then just do move
up move up move up and then I have to go
to the we recommend um you can obviously
make changes to the font the style and
every and the text so I'm going to just
click up up up and now we're going to
have shopy category we recommend and
then the new
n
and you can also change what the the
preview is this is like in Google if
someone searches it will show this uh
preview of what's going to be on the
page and you can make updates to that
you can make updates to the page title
The Meta description and there's a bunch
of things that you can uh change and you
can see it also even gives you a page
analysis so you can see the Met
description is over 160 characters so if
we change that
I'm going to just delete that so let's
try this description if we go down here
we see that we have a good content
length and then you can go through here
and fix all these and we see we have
some other problems we can go through
each one and fix them I'm not going to
take the time to do that right now but
you can do that on your own okay I'm
just going to click
update and
then we can view the page and now we can
see the updated page and it's getting
more
customized okay let's customize it
further we want to uh customize the
links up here and we can see we actually
do have the the blog here so you can see
these blog posts and we're going to
actually customize all these pages to
make it work better for what we want
first of all we want the shop to be the
second link at their home it's the most
important part since this is a shop so
to update this menu here we're have to
go back to the wp admin the WordPress
admin page and then we're going to go to
appearance and menus here I'm already on
the menus page then we're going to
create a new menu so I'll just put Main
and then we will make this the primary
menu and create
menu and we these notifications we don't
need to worry about that and now I can
add items to the menu so for first going
to add the shop top page and then we're
going to add the cart checkout and let's
just look at what's already on here we
got cart checkout my account shop so
we're going to basically add all those
same things but just change the order so
I'm also want the the blog page and I
should have been clicking add to menu
here okay so it's going to be the shop
first then
Blog then cart then
checkout then my account and then I will
save the
menu now let's go to the page and I'll
just refresh the
page okay that works shop blog cart
check out my account we don't have the
main page anymore but that's okay CU
when you click the logo here it should
load the main page and most people are
used to that so we have shop blog cart
checkout main account great and actually
I'm gonna go back to the main screen we
go to get started and we're going to go
to AI assistant so now we can see how we
can create content with AI and it's
going to be uh efor lent timesaving SEO
friendly and so we can see what type of
content do we need want to make a post a
page a product so we can make all sorts
of things with AI so um this this is
going to be why Developers
should put
stickers on
[Music]
their
laptops and we can change the tone
neutral formal TR I'm going to change
this to Friendly and witty and it'll
make
it long okay so now I'll just do
generate
content
okay good we have an image and then we
have the the article sticker up your
laptop why developers should embrace the
art of personalization as a developer
your laptop is the most prized
possession and then it talks about uh
adding a touch of Personality we're
talking about stickers and it gives all
show off your interest Foster creative
environment stand out from the crowd
it's just plain fun so I'm just going to
publish it we just now have a new
article on our blog
and I could have done edit as draft to
personalize it but now we can see we
have an article on our blog just like
this and so here's the blog
post we see this we see everything and
people can even comment on it and log in
and comment on it if we want to
customize what these blog posts look
like well one way to go about it is to
click this edit post so edit post is is
where we can actually edit the words we
can say as a developer your laptop is
your most important possession good now
it's a now this is an article actually
written by me since I put at least one
word into it and you can change all
these things and even has a page
analysis
here okay we know how to add a blog post
now let's get to the real the real stuff
of what this is this is a store so let's
customize the shop specifically let's
add new products we are going to add
stickers that people can actually buy in
real
life so if we go back to our
WordPress uh dashboard we go to
products and then it's going to show all
the products um so before we were just
using these products as examples we
don't want any of those products so I am
going to select here and then I I'm just
going to move to
bin and apply so I just select all the
products and I deleted all the products
so now we we are just about to start
adding new products but first we have to
create the products so remember these
are this is a a sticker store and we are
going to use AI to create our sticker
designs so for that we need an AI image
generator there's a plenty of them out
there like I've mentioned I'm going to
use gbd4 with uh Dolly the beta version
and if you don't have access to this
version there's plenty of other ones you
can use some of them are open source and
you can run locally or on a website and
this is what I'm going to do I'll say
create some
sticker
designs
for my sticker store
here is the description of the store and
I'll just put the description we made
earlier welcome to coders stickers.com
the premier Online Marketplace where
every sticker tells a code
story okay now I'm going to say create a
few more but the website
name should not be on
them but some of these stickers I like
I'm still going to use some of these uh
this one I like so I'm going to download
this
one and this is interesting because uh I
guess they're a bug I don't know what
that's supposed to be but sure we're
we're going to create that as a sticker
and then this is going to be a sticker
I'm going to just download that let's
see what else it comes up with
oh yeah this is I like that
one
nice okay and I'm actually going to take
all these into an image editor to kind
of cut them out to to process them
better for our
store now create a few more sticker
designs for software
Developers
now uh let's I'm going to actually
change the
prompt now make a list of sticker design
ideas for software developers then
create the best
ideas so we're going to see if it can
create better stickers if it first
creates the
list
okay let's look at
these oh these are really cool actually
I'm G to do that one that
one actually I don't know if I can do
this one because it's
um it's kind of cut off on the
edge uh but this one is also going to be
a good one
this is almost like a devops sticker now
what I'm going to do I'm going to go
into my image editor okay I'm using
Affinity photo but you may be using
Photoshop there's also canva and there's
a lot of free online image editors you
can use so you can basically do this in
any image editor so what I'm going to do
is uh basically delete all the parts
that are not going to be in the sticker
uh we want it to be uh transparent
around the actual sticker so I'm going
to select this I will um select this
let's see if I change the tolerance
that's too much
so I deleted everything around but then
I need to add some stuff back I'm I'm
going to add a white
outline okay now I just have to delete a
few extra things
here and then I'll crop the image so we
can see we have the transparent stuff
around the image and then we do have a
white border around
everything and then I'm going to save it
and then I'll just start on another one
this should be pretty easy to select
out usually I like to put a white line
around it but this one I'm not I'll just
save it just like this and then another
one and then I'll just do a few more off
camera so I made a bunch of stickers and
I want to make it so people can actually
buy the stickers I found this website
called printful there's a few other
websites like this where they will print
on demand uh this is not the only one
you can use there's a few other ones but
I'm actually going to create the
stickers on printful and then add them
to my WordPress site and then people
will actually be able to order and then
they will print them on demand so first
I have to make a new product so if I go
to product
catalog
um
actually so if I go to product template
I'll say create
product and then I just go to
stickers I can search for stickers
and we want kiss cut stickers um mainly
this is the cheapest type of stickers
and a kiss cut sticker means it will be
cut out along the edge of the sticker
that's why we needed the
transparency because uh the transparency
is where it will be um cut off so I'm
just going to drag my sticker design
into
here and I could add a few other
different types of products but I'm not
going to but we can see what it's going
to look up look like I can click
mockups and then you can see what it's
going to look like on a a a computer or
a car and you can see the transparency
it doesn't become any part of the
sticker so that's why we need to create
that
transparency okay so now that we have
the sticker we can also choose what
sizes we want I'll just keep all the
sizes though I think the small sizes
will will be better for the sticker and
I'll just do save to templates
and then I'm going to add the rest of
the stickers just like that but we still
see we have a a few of them here so I'm
going to do add to store and I need to
connect a
store so let's just click connect
store and then I'll go to choose
platform and then I just want to find
WordPress oh W commas it's right here so
connecting to
woocommerce and it's basically going to
give instructions here but I'll just
show you how to do it we're going to go
back to our WordPress settings we go to
Blue Commerce and then I'm going to go
to
settings if I go to Advanced and uh it's
going to keep showing this this we can
do this if we want but we're not going
to connect but I'm going to go to um
Legacy
API and then enable the Legacy rest
API so the next thing we need to do is
make sure the Perman links are set up
correctly so go to settings Pera
links and then I'm going to swi switch
it to post
name so this is something we probably
wanted to do anyways where the links uh
in the the default was just going to be
like P1 23 but now it's going to
actually say the name of the post right
in the URL which I think looks a little
nicer
and it's going to be better for SEO as
well so I'm going to go to save changes
for
that and now we can see if the
woocommerce API is working so to do that
I'm going to go to the code stickers.com
and I'm going to type in WC API that's
woocommerce
V1 and so now that we're getting this
Json that means the API is working
correctly okay now I'm going to go back
to um plugins we haven't really talked
too much about plugins but they can be
used to add extra features to
whoops they can be used to add extra
features to your site and we talked
about some of the default uh plugins
that get installed we're going to
install the printful plug-in so I'm
going to click add new
and then I'll
search and then
install and then I have to activate
it and now we'll have a new tab here the
printful tab so let me click
here and it says almost done just two
more steps so I'm going
to so I'm going to click
connect follow
link and I'm going to approve
this now I just have to log in
again and connect
store okay now I'm just going to add
product
my product
templates and I'm going
to okay proceed to
mockups and we'll just do basic
mockups so we're going to do this mockup
or just has the computer in the
middle and then
continue and we don't have to become a
member that just gives us different
rates so the retail price must be higher
than the printful
price okay now we can basically set the
price so I'm just making it so they go
at least a little more than the printful
price I'm actually just going to make it
so I make $1 for every
sticker okay and submit to store make I
know it's called Bubble free stickers
but I want to change what the the title
is so this is GNA be
called
coffee
coding
sticker I'm going to click where it says
View and woo
Commerce okay we have all the different
uh computer mockups here and you can
choose the size add to basket
it and then we
can then if we go to
cart we can see that we have the
sticker I'm going go over to printful
and add some more now I'm just going to
upload the rest of the images and create
the rest of the
products okay just added a bunch more
stickers well not a bunch but a few
extra and so you can all obviously
customize what the images and what the
mockups going to look like but now that
they're all added I'm going to go to
view in woo Commerce let's look at what
our woocommerce store looks like I'm
going to go right to the shop page and
now we can see the the different
stickers the Bas and Bug sticker bug
catcher cod's art coffee coating sticker
devops coaster
sticker idea machine sticker uh USB tree
I guess I forgot to type in sticker
there
uh so these are all the the stickers you
can get in the shop and so if we go into
one then we can select options so I'll
just select
the depending on on what you select it's
going to uh change the size it's going
to uh change the skew and it's going to
make it look a different size on the the
laptop
mockup so if we go to 3x3 I can add that
to
basket and then go to the cart now we
have the two things we have the coffee
coating sticker we have the USB tree and
then we'll just do proceed to check
out so if if we look down here we can
see it's just basically another a normal
cart and uh there's a few things we can
see one is that there are no available
payment method so we have to set up the
payment methods and the second thing is
that I don't think I want to see these
recent blog post on the side here so
let's fix both of those
things to remove this sidebar on the
cart page and some other places um
depending on what theme you have you can
click
customize and there for some themes
there will be a way to customize it from
in here however with this theme it's
going to be a little trickier
we have to go to our dashboard and we're
going to actually have to edit a PHP
file uh it's sounds kind of tricky but
it's not as it's not not as hard as you
would think we can go to appearance and
then theme file editor and then click I
understand now we are going to edit the
functions.php file so I'm just going to
scroll down to this bottom of this page
and we're going to ignore where it says
do not add Cod custom code here because
we are going to add a custom code you
just have to remember that if you update
it's it's going to um remove it so you
may have to add it again if you update
so I'm just going to paste in some code
here and this is the function remove
storefront sidebar it's going to check
if it's woocommerce or if it's the
checkout then it's going to do a remove
action and we have ADD action where it's
going to this is where it's going to
call the function remove storefront
sidebar
so I'm going to update that
file now I just have to update one more
file which is the CSS file so going to
style. CS CSS and then I can just scroll
to the bottom of this one and I'm going
to add this I'm going to make the width
100% for by. woocommerce and body.
woocommerce
checkout and then I'll just hit update
file and then if we go back back to our
page and we go to the checkout page you
can see we don't
have the sidebar anymore here so here's
the checkout
page and you can see it says sorry it
seems like there are no available
payment methods please con so we
basically have to add some payment
methods that's that's going to be the
next step here so I'm going to go to the
dashboard
and then I'm going to click on payments
right here so we will install woo
payments and you can see that there are
no step costs or monthly fees it just
takes a fee basically out of each sale
that you
make okay I'll just go through the
setup
process I decided not to show you that
because there was a ton of personal
information to get the payment set up
that I don't want to share with with
everybody but we got that set up and you
can figure that out on your own if if
you're doing the setup it's pretty
straightforward and so it says
congratulations your store has been
verified so you can see that we are
paying 27 cents per transaction Plus
2.61 or it normally be 30 cents per
transaction I'm only making a dollar so
that would be basically 70 cents per
sticker we also have to make sure we set
up our our shipping and taxes so to get
our shipping set up I'm going to go to
settings woocommerce
settings and then I will go to ship to
all countries you sell to I also want to
enable tax ring calculations I might as
well turn off the coupon codes right
here and then I'm going to save
changes and then go to
shipping so I'm going to go to print
full
shipping enable this shipping method
disable standard wo Commerce rates for
products fulfilled by
printful so we want to enable sh the
shipping this shipping method the
printful shipping method we want to
disable standard woocommerce rat for
products fulfilled by printful so
printful is going to just handle all the
shipping and then we are going to set
which shipping methods we want printful
use so we have to go to the printful tab
here then I'll go to the settings tab
and then I can allow printf to calculate
the sales
tax and I'll keep going
down to these shipping
methods so these are all the shipping
methods that are offered from pimpl and
I'm just going to keep all of these I
mean I I could if I didn't want to offer
some I could could take them off but
those all look pretty good to
me
okay I'll save the changes because of
the tax button I clicked
here now let's go to the
site look at the cart my cart's empty
I'm going go to the
shop
and I'm going to choose this USB
tree 3x3 actually I'll do the
4x4 I'll add the
basket now I can go to the check
out oh air missing or invalid printful
store Key we have something not working
for that so let me go to the dashboard
again I did notice when I was in
settings I'm going to try reconnecting
the
store okay now it's actually showing the
shipping so I can click a flat rate so
we're paying it's kind of an expensive
sticker $3.40 for the sticker and then
$3.99 for the
shipping so it's it going to be a total
of$
783 okay
sure and then I place my order and it
says order received okay so let's see
what the order looks like in the
dashboard so I go to the
dashboard and if we go to woocommerce
and orders now you can see there's going
to be two orders I tried an order before
that didn't really work out be um so
this is the the other order I made that
I kind of messed up on so if we go to
this order so hopefully this order will
go through if we go back to printf and
we go to orders hopefully we'll see the
order that's going oh okay it says it's
failed no billing method added okay I
have to add a billing method because uh
stripe took the money and then we have
to send it over to print full so addit
building
method so I just set up the build method
on printful and how it works is first
the customer pays me and then I have to
pay printful and then hopefully I make
some sort of profit so the first money
comes to me and then I pay printful
based on the money that came to me so
let me try just uh purchasing the
sticker one more time so I'm going to
click USB
tree add the
basket check out
okay I've placed the order now I'm going
to look at PRL again on the order
dashboard if I refresh this okay it
didn't fail it's it's waiting for
fulfillment so this sticker is actually
going to be sent to me it says orders
waiting for fulfillment estimated
fulfillment October 20th through 25th
that means our store is pretty much done
I me we can go through and customize
things more so all that's left now is to
add more products and use the AI tools
to add more blog post to help with SEO
we've reached the end of the course you
can endlessly customize your site but
we've implemented all the basic
functionality With a Little Help from
artificial intelligence so good luck on
creating your own site or web store